[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
dude what about when people are like oh
i can't believe you were in town just
missed you oh dude that is the bane bro
dude it's so hard to not go nuts yeah
about that i go nuts about that it's so
i can't believe i missed you can't
believe i didn't know you were here yeah
you well i'm how about that when they
tag it with this i'm your biggest fan
yeah no you're not dude
i was in your city
2 000 people knew it
2 000 people sat in those seats
those fans there are 2 000
bigger fans of me in your city yeah you
shouldn't even go outdoors bro bro
you're embarrassing yeah and it doesn't
even you don't even get it
and it's and it's and the [ __ ] up
thing is for me to say
that it's embarrassing i sound elitist
but [ __ ] that it's still you're
embarrassing it's embarrassing and
here's what else you a fan of do you
love your mother do you love your
[ __ ] family probably not no probably
not not as much as you think you'd
probably not
as a matter of fact if i had a son and
he was whoever's biggest fan and he
missed
their show yeah and he said but i'm
their biggest fan
i re-evaluate my whole relationship with
that son dude for real man
it's very scary i have great chest hair
too oh wow and somebody saw it the other
day on a video and it was like 70 people
said something yeah yeah yeah first it
hurt my feelings didn't remind me of my
grandfather well and that's kind of not
bittersweet but also
uh
to have 70 people talking about your
[ __ ] gray chest hair that means you
made it yeah if you have 70 people
talking about your gray chess here you
made it yeah
yeah
but you're we're the same age
yeah i know you are a couple months
younger than me i'm 39. but that's we
would say same age yeah in life you
wouldn't be like no i'm a few months
older than you because that would be so
weird
yeah like we're both 39 you wouldn't be
like no we're not the same age my
birthday's first yeah yeah well tell
them how old you really are yeah
it's just a couple days earlier
yeah
oh that's like asking if somebody told
me by the way we lie you're 45 i'd be
like that makes a lot of sense
on youtube and [ __ ] people are watching
very visual i mean look at rap now look
you got to have orange and purple and
pink hair takashi
and face tattoos takashi bruh yeah
nobody's about to nobody's even about
the [ __ ] music anymore yeah you know
if takashi hits you up bro really right
yeah he hits you up to like you get an
email in the middle yeah yeah yeah first
of all it's awesome to think that he
emails
okay
how about this dude you get a owl that
drops a letter through your [ __ ]
letterbox that's more like him and the
owl is yellow and purple and orange yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay yeah the owl
has his long hair and it's in his eyes
bro he's flying all crazy maybe he has
68 above it
yeah and you get a letter and it's it
for him for from it's from him to come
down to like dominican republic or
wherever he keeps claiming he lives
um do you go do you go
uh no way no for what you would i'd go
yeah yeah i would hate that dude i'd
hate to be [ __ ] some guy from a long
time ago
yeah
yeah i would imagine that
like it's hard enough probably banging
some guy you don't even want to [ __ ]
these days you know but imagine a
thousand years ago banging some dude
when people are like hey you know people
think it's magic people don't know what
it is yeah and i'll also tell you that
they were not clean oh they were so
dirty they were just outside a lot more
you know all the hair on them yeah yeah
yeah different times dude
bro don't make that sound that's one of
the worst sounds people make yeah my
freaking grandfather is always making
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and you love good humor man you love it
yeah yeah it's crazy bro almost how much
you love like you really love it yeah i
laugh so much dude i mean like one of my
favorite things to do is to get you know
sometimes you come eat but like after
the show is to like go to a diet
we're all making fun of each other what
about that one guy that like who he's
with both of his he still uses both
utensils at the same time oh is that joe
i don't know joe's a weirdo yeah just
there's some some guys in chicago he
keeps having a beard and then not having
a beer yeah yeah yeah that's joe yeah
he's a weird [ __ ] right over this like
he works for his food and he has to be
there yeah yeah yeah and it always
somehow looks like he has two jackets
even though he only has one jacket i
always joke with him i say like
it always looks like you're wearing a
backpack even though you're not that guy
[ __ ] always is wearing a backpack i
don't give a [ __ ] if he's naked he's got
a backpack
it looks like he was married and had a
family at like nine years old like he
[ __ ]
looks like he's been through too much oh
man dude how many waiters at macaroni
grill did you look like over the years
whenever
whenever you went in there
honestly
i've i will tell you this straight up
i've never been a macaroni oh bro i know
you don't believe me but bro i've never
been a macaroni probably i know i know i
know i get it i wouldn't believe me if a
guy like me said i've never been a
macaroni i'd be like get the [ __ ] out
here i would never trust that guy but
i've never been see would be cool if
your kids were immediately the same
height as you like once they hit like
nine years old or 11. that would
probably be an advanced package you'd
have to buy yeah but can you imagine
dude some 11 year old same height you
know i would do weaker neck and arms
though [ __ ] calf power i'd have my
kid have a calf power because like
twenty percent you know like maximum
twenty pounds yeah yeah
[ __ ] man man look at the calves and that
guy brown eyes not blue eyes no way have
you ever met a guy with blue eyes blue
eyes no i don't have blue what are your
eyes dude look at me i'm five feet away
from you you got like brown eyes green
eyes yeah yeah i would never toast a guy
with blue eyes just hands down i you
know it's just
but it's not bizarre i'll tell you what
gianni i better tell you what nick
that's not sexy to have blue eyes as a
guy yeah yeah you don't think so also
blonde hair
you're pushing it
uh
yeah you don't have blond hair as a guy
a guy with blonde hair no i got a blind
hair blue eyes no way yeah because
here's the thing
you got to look good in a [ __ ]
black leather jacket as a dude and if
you have blonde hair you don't you got
to wear a brown leather jacket oh brown
leather jackets that my mom wears but
but but it's okay to wear a brown
leather jacket sometimes but if you're a
blonde guy you gotta wear it all the
time and that's not okay i don't know
well i do and that's how it is yeah yeah
oh i didn't i'm glad somebody hadn't
spent my time thinking about this [ __ ] i
mean you want the kind of people that
they'll die for you if you have to
it's never going to come down to that
but yes do you think there's somebody
out there that would what one of your
fans that would die for you oh i don't
know
well there's crazy people out there so
so yes
that's crazy bro but but but you do too
i got some people that might [ __ ]
pull their hair out
[Laughter]
that's not a comment on how powerful i
am that's a comment on how sad people
are it is
i think you have people that would
probably at least
like shock themselves for you okay you
know what i'm talking about a heavy
electric shock yeah heavy heavy okay
yeah yeah something that's going to shut
them down or a failed
attempt yeah for me
maybe jump off a building yeah it'd be
like well you know that's going to
happen and you knew it how high what
what if the bill was
if it's only all right so you're at
probably maybe two stories
i meant somebody jumping off their
balcony maybe
you're at like about six stories maybe
something like [ __ ] it maybe at all
to take care of yourself do you well i
work out a lot you do yeah um
and because like i get i get
bored on the road but then also i just
was like
i want to do action movies yeah like
like so like i'm like if i gonna do that
i have to actually do
actual work you have to look the part
yeah so so i started working out really
[ __ ] hard are you doing unique types
of training because you seem like
somebody that doesn't do i see you in
some of your videos i see you you know i
know that they have the shoulder
documentary thing that people were you
know that they're pitching and stuff and
i know the shoulders are outside right
now no the the doctor the guy the crew
oh they are i try to speed away but
they're [ __ ] good drivers yeah yeah
oh that's crazy man well it's a
traperrazzi too they're trying to get
pictures of people's trash right
and but are you doing anything like a
unique training i see you doing like
american ninja words stuff when i think
of you and get jealous a little some of
the jealous thoughts i have a review
swinging off so different the thoughts
of me the jealous thoughts of me are all
about me being active i like that a lot
yeah now they are since you told me you
wanted to be an action hero right so
so you've had those jealous thoughts for
about 35 seconds yeah no i've had them
provided six or seven years okay okay
i remember
somebody they came they offered me
uh
something i can't remember what the show
was something with pirates or something
no see i would just said yes and a
heartbeat to that
you know what i mean just to do that
bro i don't see how some movie maker
doesn't look out and see like a ship
coming into a new land and you're on it
bro dude you're at the front maybe
who you telling bro yeah that's true
i know
i know
i'm on the front of that [ __ ]
i know dude
oh [ __ ] and you have both your legs
still and people are [ __ ] just how
did he do it how did he get 38 with both
of those legs
i'm still here because i'm still here
[ __ ] yeah what i've been
working on a lot lately is a lot of what
is it is when i when i'm staring at
somebody
and then they look at me
you know the instinct is to look away
but that's a [ __ ] move
you gotta keep staring at him if they're
if you're staring at him and they catch
you you're like this is what i was doing
and i'm not stopping because you chose
to live your life well that is something
you got to do that i've been working on
that is very hard for some reason isn't
that weird
yes very hard because it's extremely
unnatural i know it's very unnatural but
i think that we can switch that i think
that we can change that i think we can
change that i want because here's the
thing i want my kids to [ __ ] do that
right so i have to work on it for myself
and this way when they're growing up and
they see me doing that
yeah they're gonna be really gonna be in
the front yard just looking at the
[ __ ] neighbors yeah i can't wait i i
actually can't wait the neighbors out
there picking up dog [ __ ] and looks over
at them they don't look like
like a [ __ ] serial killer
what the [ __ ] is wrong with those kids
and then i and then i and then i call
them
and they go hello and i say nothing
click
you think there's a lot of dads that
ever hugged their sons and be like man
my son ain't [ __ ]
you know what i hope so yeah
but i also hope that secretly they were
like but i [ __ ] up too yeah yeah yeah
you know what i mean right like yeah
he's not [ __ ] but i'm all you know yeah
i'm realizing that i'm not [ __ ] either
if he's not [ __ ] did you know what i'm
realizing if we had a podcast together
yeah it would take over you think yeah i
do think so really yeah
well maybe we'll think about that but
yeah that would be [ __ ] insane bro
are you i think we're too yeah we're
just so different though that's why it's
good yeah just two white guys kicking it
oh yeah dude
the endangered species podcast
because we're going out of [ __ ]
business man i don't want to do so much
[ __ ] like there's like three things i
like doing
you know
and and sometimes jerking off and coming
is one of them so don't take that from
me don't try to yeah don't try to don't
try to like be like i feel bad yeah
you're right i wish i did it man i wish
it was awesome like i just got up in the
morning like i'm gonna [ __ ] jerk off
real quick and then enjoy the rest of my
experience today it's just not how it
works for me that's a question do you
and i don't even really like talking
about this but do you do you take your
time doing it or did you just do it to
get it done um
i usually i can get it done in less than
a minute i don't ever take more than two
minutes
that might be one of your problems you
think so take yourself out onto the date
bro yeah yeah you know like go out to
dinner
do something nice you know what i mean
go to like [ __ ] pizza cucina or some
nice [ __ ] i don't even know if that's a
place but like some place that would
sound like that and go go to like a
hearties that has an upstairs yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah a hundred percent be like
yeah were they you're like are you guys
seating up there yeah and they'd be like
nah nah i'm like i'm on a nice date all
right we got one seat up there sorry
you just sit there you drink some wine
or whatever you don't drink but like you
get some club soda yeah you just [ __ ]
you have a conversation with yourself
you know
like not out loud but in your head and
then you go home and you [ __ ] think
and like you know that was nice yeah and
if there was somebody there you would be
like that was very nice wasn't it and
they'd be like yeah it was nice yeah
have a good time dude shake hands with
who the [ __ ] you are bro go home turn on
some netflix maybe watch [ __ ] always
be my maybe and then afterwards or in
the middle you know what i mean because
you know when you're watching the
netflix or the girl is it or do you keep
going now you keep it going oh wow yeah
no you don't though think about it think
about if you're with a chick you don't
pause it i pause it a little bit pause
it yeah that's a boss move wow you're an
alpha am i bro
think about that [ __ ] you're watching a
movie with a chick you're watching you
just go
boop amazing bro i don't pause it i'm
you know why i'm too scared
yeah bro you keep it going you go like
well
[Music]
you know
you gotta pause it man you already
watched 11 [ __ ] 12 minutes it's like
i saw a video of lebron's uh kid playing
basketball and he's okay
well no they say oh he's really good but
it's like
how good you gotta be
how good is he gonna be yeah you gotta
be the best which you can't be because
your dad's the best right that's what
i'm saying dude imagine if your [ __ ]
dad was the best that's what i'm saying
it's like imagine ugh
or uh you know it's like any of that
like meryl streep's daughter is doing
she's an actress dude my dad was 70 when
i was born right i remember my dad
[ __ ] got this buick he bought it from
some black dudes in our neighborhood he
couldn't hear that good yeah it had 12
like 22s or something in the back of it
right oh wow so we had this cutlass 88
and he would drive around
with just base bro just taking your dad
yeah at 70. oh but 80. this is at 80
because so you were 10. this is when i
was 10 yeah and he would just drive
around one of the speakers blew out and
he got a bunch of chinese food and [ __ ]
in there bro and it literally rattled
for like two years just crossed it out
oh my god i mean he was kind of great he
did you know he lived by himself so he
had to take care of himself but so
you're saying it was easier for you to
become better oh yeah
like the [ __ ] finish line
the finish line is right next to the
starting line i don't think about the
[ __ ] that matters yeah you don't it's
not fun i [ __ ] just worry about the
[ __ ] that matters yeah but you also have
that [ __ ] thing where it's like i
wonder what bobby looked like with
different lips like think about that
yeah i just want i mean i think about
bobby a lot dude because i worry that
he's just not living up to his full
potential right so you think about that
which is very nice but also you might
think
you know
what it's like inside of his girl
oh no well i have a weird thing and it
might be a shortcoming about how like
once somebody recognizes
i've done something i don't want to like
like i did that the drunk girls bit that
i did went viral and once and once that
went viral i'm like i will never do that
on stage again wow i don't want to be
like once somebody knows me from
something i don't want to ever do it
again like i [ __ ]
like i was one of the first people on
vine with a million followers
i hated that app because everyone then
oh then it got real not funny right and
people were like what's up when your
girl walks by and
you know what i mean it's like what
and then there's a a a mclaren in the
vine for some reason and you're like
where'd they get this [ __ ] mclaren
from yeah somebody's eating marshmallows
or something yeah what's that next level
you think owning a tank nah well i'll
tell you what dude
um
if i had
i could see you getting a tank if i had
like
i mean because here's the thing though
but first of all
you can't keep a tank in la right so so
you not only do you need the money for
the tank you need the money for [ __ ]
to transport the tanker to wherever
happens okay you have to get this thing
you have to get it air lifted in i would
say i would keep you know you could
probably keep it you could probably keep
it somewhere [ __ ] shitty like
albuquerque you could probably keep it
in albuquerque yeah
they would actually probably love it if
i kept a tank there do you know what i'm
saying yeah you'd have to yeah they'd be
like oh chris lee keep the tank yeah you
know albuquerque the albuquerque would
literally be like you know uh
albuquerque is great because we have you
know whatever the crops they have and
then also crystalline keeps his tank
here yeah spices they have spices i
think yeah they probably do because it's
close unique peppers oh i remember on
the news that lady got mad at you on the
news and now yeah
yep yep and you made the news bro did
that blow your mind so yeah the number
one thing about that is frats like you
would never join a fret join right join
something
are you out of your mind
join something yeah
my grandfather used to tell my dad you
never volunteer for anything wow dude
that's hilarious
that's hilarious and as a kid i was like
what but now i get it dude yeah it's
like that lil wayne song i'm me dude
yeah get out of here frat yeah come on
have you met little wayne
no
no no i would though i would love to
dude i got invited um
so i got invited to
uh
this it was some saints after party
during like a uh
nba all-star weekend this is like 15
years ago oh yeah right 12 years ago
yeah and once yeah so i go in and it
ends up being in this little bitty
conference room at like this um at this
westin or something right and it's
amazing like there's so many like the
kardashians are there before they're
like as huge as they are it's kind of
crazy wow and then manny fresh and
little wayne many fresh wow yeah dressed
up like an astronaut bro in a total huge
hat and the suit was too big they should
not have put this big of an astronaut
comes in and he's literally rapping and
like uh
and they did one song and they jetted
man but that was the closer i ever got
to him oh my god i've never even seen
lil wayne yeah a lot of people in new
orleans look like they're lil wayne
though oh yeah well that's a thing there
like you have that haircut i don't know
if you think that that's dope or funny
or both but that makes it dope to me
right do you know what i'm saying yeah
that makes it sexy yeah i don't even
know i know i feel like a lot of guys
are probably intimidated by you like in
the comedy space and i probably was i
think you know when i think back um
but then like you know you've done like
some really nice things for me uh even
just like helping me get in over the
laugh factory oh yeah and like um
you know just uh
you know like you'll tag your buddies on
social media like you'll do stuff that's
like
super nice do you feel like people
um have a misconception about you ever
and this could have just been me and my
own inferiority well i don't know i
think that people think
people judge people and that's fine you
know until you get to know somebody but
if you're like like i think a lot of
people
you know um
you know
like i like fashion i wear a cool jacket
i get what people think about that when
they see a long-haired dude with a
[ __ ] beard and a and a big and a
jacket yeah max amini yeah
but no you're like you're like you're
like oh that guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right he thinks he's funny he's also an
[ __ ] from like the 70s yeah yeah yeah
yeah those of you that don't know what a
writer is maybe yeah that comic snow and
musicians but it's like what is in the
green room when you arrive to a show
and you guys literally have
the coffee the ice americano you got
club soda water
and then you got
my toothbrush and toothpaste which i
also get yeah what really what is that
do you got a writer what's in yours
uh i don't i don't here's my thing i
don't mind if there's a plate of turkey
deli meat in the in the room that's the
only thing that's where mine is that's a
good one i have so yeah i have this and
then i have vegetables
and then uh
and then i have um
uh what else do i have uh tabasco sauce
yeah for what the salmon that i also get
oh yeah yeah that's beautiful man yeah
and do you uh
are you pretty adamant about those
things like right when they get there
those people know now
no i mean
they're pretty good about it usually but
some places you show up and they're just
like all right cool let's start the show
and then you never get your [ __ ] and
you're like what the [ __ ] yeah yeah but
i think that that's just that has
nothing to do with like you know i think
that some places just aren't good at you
know having your [ __ ] it's funny it
sounds like a diva thing but like you
know sometimes you count on it to eat
like you show up and you're like i
haven't eaten i can't wait to eat that
salmon and you show up and it's nothing
they're like what yeah and it's just
somebody's yeah it's just a dude
standing there
yeah yeah like remember just like
reciting like old vines you did
you're like damn this is not you're like
just yeah yeah like does one of these
end in my salmon
um
[Music]
ain't no right way just the wrong way
[Music]